[Musique]
bienvenue sur les plateaux de l'année
date à venir le festival de cannes a
ouvert le 6 juillet et l'on y parle des
plateformes de vidéo à la demande par
abonnement
netflix amazon disney plus apple tv et
cetera
on y parle de chronologie des médias
mais aussi du smad entrée en vigueur le
1er juillet qui veut imposer aux plates
formes en fonction de leur chiffre
d'affaires en france des obligations
d'investissement dans la création
audiovisuelle et cinématographique de
notre pays
et puis surtout on se demande s'il est
celle de cinéma ont encore de l'avenir
si l'avenir du cinéma
ce ne sont pas les plateformes justement
pour en débattre nous avons invité jean
baptiste thoret historiens ex critique
de cinéma on vous doit notamment un
livre de référence sur le cinéma
américain des années 70 mais aussi 26
secondes l'amérique éclaboussé soit
l'affluence de l'assassinât de kennedy
sur le cinéma il y à vos films aussi le
dernier c'est mickaël qui mignot à
mirage américain qui sortiraient
ensemble en salles en novembre
et puis vos conférences filmées sur
youtube
jean baptiste aurez vous êtes le premier
à qui je pose la question est ce que les
plateformes sur l'avenir du cinéma
d'après vous écoutez je pense qu'on est
tellement au milieu du guet que c'est
très compliqué de répondre de façon un
peu frein franche et déterminer là
dessus moi j'aurais pu temps plutôt
envie de me poser la question de quel
cinéma on parle je pense que c'est celle
à venir des contenus voilà au sens où on
prépare l'avenir du confluent absolument
je pensais battant que sont la viande
est contenu maintenant est ce que le
cinéma est soluble en tant que contenu
parmi d'autres ça j'en suis beaucoup
moins sûr et je pense que tout le noeud
est véritablement là est ce que le
cinéma c'est quelque chose qui est juste
projeté sur un écran peu importe sur un
écran d'ordinateur un ipad ou une salle
de cinéma où le cinéma autrement dit les
films c'est un peu plus que ça auquel
cas je dirais que le mariage entre la
plateforme et de cinéma à mon avis reste
à prouver que et de la porte vous est ce
ce kellogg ancienne enseignante
chercheuse en socio-économie du cinéma
et de l'audiovisuel
vos travaux portent essentiellement sur
les conditions de diffusion et de
circulation des films êtes l'auteur de
cinéma et internet représentation
circulation réception c'est paru aux
éditions de l'harmattan les plateformes
sur l'avenir du cinéma pour vous non non
je crois pas je rejoins plus tôt jean
baptiste aurait sur la différence qu'il
faut faire entre les deux j'en parlerai
plus comme d'un voisin je pense qu'il va
y avoir un voisinage force et on va en
reparler certainement aujourd'hui alors
un voisin ça peut être un voisin
sympathique qui des peines de la farine
et des oeufs et puis ça peut construire
une grande clôture au bord de son propre
jardin donc ça va impliquer des choses
différentes mais pour moi ça s'il n'y a
pas de concurrence directement ces deux
choses assez différentes avec des
synergies des concurrences des choses
qui superpose mais qui sont in fine est
en fait pas la même chose parce qu'elle
le chevalier consultant chez watson une
agence que vous avez fondé spécialisée
dans la dématérialisation et les médias
avant cela vous étiez chez tf1 où vous
développiez les activités vidéo vous
avez créé tf a vidé au point fr un des
premiers sites notamment de ventes de
dvd sur internet et tf1 vision qui est
devenu aujourd'hui
mytf1 vod les plateformes c'est l'avenir
du cinéma pour vous les plateformes sont
le complément de la salle de cinéma
il va falloir s'habituer à vivre avec et
c'est un nouvel univers qui est en train
de se créer de s'écrire mais pour moi il
ya une réelle complémentarité entre
l'expérience de la salle et l'expérience
de la plateforme
j'aimerais qu'on parle de cette
expérience de la salle est ce que les
salles de cinéma ont encore un avenir à
part pour voir fast and furious numéro
10 ou spider man 10 u 17
est ce que est ce que la salle de cinéma
est encore le temple d'une religion qui
s'appelle le cinéma et dans lequel nous
avons baigné vous aviez vous avez baigné
jean baptiste thoret moi aussi quand
j'étais adolescent on allait au cinéma
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est encore le
cas je réponds à cette question si vous
c'est une question qui est très
compliqué parce que il ya un peu de caen
j'ai subi en tant que je dirais amateurs
de cinéma cinéphiles ou même parfois on
saigne en fac ou critique c'est le camp
de ceux qui considèrent qu'un film ne
peut être vu quand ça de cinéma autant
comme vous dites qui après c'est
quasiment un acteur religieux voire
mystique en dehors du cinéma
la salle de cinéma le film n'existe pas
et puis il ya les autres
kan auquel j'appartiens plus tôt j'ai
tendance à me dire que ce qui est le
plus important d'abord d'abord c'est de
voir des films
alors évidemment c'est toujours mieux
quand on les voit en salles de cinéma
mais quand on habite à paris à lyon ou à
marseille ou à new york ou à rome c'est
assez facile de dire ça il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où beaucoup de terrains ou
territoire dans lequel les salles de
cinéma sont pas si accessible que ça aux
états unis vous sortez des grandes
villes il ya quasiment plus de salles
art et essai par exemple donc moi
j'aurais tendance à dire oui
effectivement c'est très important de
voir les films en salle mais ce n'est
pas exclusif le plus important me
semble-t-il c'est de ces deux c'est de
voir des films
donc je pense que la salle de cinéma un
avenir le vrai problème en france c'est
qu'on a cinq 5 ou 6000 écran qu'on a
3000 salles de cinéma est ce que par
rapport à la à l'évolution des
spectateurs aujourd'hui par rapport à la
jeune génération moi qui m'obsède un peu
parce que les crânes gris et les shows
dans les salles art et essai je me dis
que dans dix ans ils sont plus là donc
faut s'intéresser à la génération qui
vient
et cette génération qui vient est ce que
le parc de cinéma n'est pas un peu me
semble-t-il surdimensionné par rapport
par rapport à l autrement dit est-ce que
le modèle d'exploitation et de
distribution qui a fait des grands jours
du cinéma en france dans les années
60-70 c'est même encore un peu 80's
qu'il est encore à la taille ou à la
mesure de prédire de l'appétit à
déterminer d'ailleurs de pour la jeune
génération pour le cinéma est ce que la
jeune génération a autant un désir de
cinéma que la mienne par exemple ou que
la nôtre ça c'est mon avis une vraie
question
et qui va produire sans doute des
bouleversements un peu tectoniques
presque indépendant de la question de la
plateforme la plateforme neiges elle
s'inscrit dans lé dans les failles ldlc
com la nature elle a horreur du vide dès
qu'elle voit qu'il ya un truc à faire
elle y va donc elle profite à la fois
elle a sa vie propre mais elle procès
profite aussi des faiblesses
on pourrait dire bouddha métamorphose du
cinéma en gros la question moi que je me
pose c'est est ce que le cinéma est
encore ou pas un art populaire
c'est ça la vraie question on va se la
poser juste après mais d'abord sur la
salle de cinéma que de la porte
oui si la question qui était posée c'est
ce que la salle reste est ce que la
pratique reste et est ce que les salles
continue d'exister oui on a les chiffres
sur la fréquentation de gens qui sont
des très bons chiffres qui font plaisir
à beaucoup d'exploitants et
distributeurs on a une fréquentation des
jeunes publics
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites parce qu'il est question de de
l'offre effectivement il ya beaucoup de
salles en france c'est plutôt quelque
chose d'intéressant et une richesse pour
la france et d'ailleurs si on regarde
les derniers chiffres sur la
fréquentation la part de marché des
salles en zone rurale et dans les
agglomérations de moins de vingt mille
habitants sont enfin c'est la part de
marché qui a le plus progressé sur
l'année 2020 alors qui est certes une
année un peu particulière mais on voit
bien qu'il n'ya pas d'affolement de la
salle les gens continuent d'y aller les
salles sont fréquentés et c'est donc je
jouis la salle reste se maintient très
bien avec des bots chivres pas forcément
avec exactement les mêmes public quoique
je moi je suis très sceptique sur ce
discours disant que les jeunes
déserteraient les salles de cinéma ce
n'est pas ce que disent les chiffres ça
n'est pas ce que disent les chiffres du
cnc ça n'est pas ce que disent les
chiffres du ministère de la culture
donc il ya des enjeux économiques mais
la question de la pratique en tout cas
si on parle du cinéma comme d'une
pratique comme d'une pratique collective
de visionnages en salle ça ça se
maintient les dirigeants du club et je
ne suis pas catastrophiste pleurer quand
on cite les chiffres moi je me méfie
parce que c'est vrai vous avez raison la
fréquentation est là et je me souviens
de la patronne du cnc tout heureux je
crois que c'est en 2018
parce qu'il y avait eu autant de
français qui étaient allés au cinéma en
2018 qu'en 1968
je crois que c'est vous qui aviez fait
des commentaires que je suis
et à l'époque dans le magazine lui jean
baptiste horreur disant oui certes ils
étaient aussi nombreux mais ils
n'étaient pas du tout aller voir les
mêmes films c'est à dire qu'en 68 ans
allait voir kubrick
on allait voir le lauréat on allait voir
c'était ça les films qui avaient le plus
marché
c'était c'était des films qu'on voit
encore cinquante ans plus tard
et puis qu'est-ce qu'on est allé voir en
2010 huit fast furious 10 spider man 14
il fonce et cetera les films de philippe
lachaux voilà les films de philippe la
chaussée sur votre est sympa mais c'est
pas lui de funès voiliers et parce qu'il
y avait louis de funès aussi en en 68
donc c'est pour ça la fréquentation ok
mais qu'est ce qu'on va voir
pascal lechevallier d'abord la salle est
un lieu absolument sacré aujourd'hui
parce que les conditions de visionnage
les efforts qui ont été faits par les
exploitants part par la technique nous
permet vraiment d'avoir une expérience
qu'on ne peut pas retrouver ailleurs
donc ça pour moi la salle va rester
comme un théâtre un lieu exceptionnel où
on peut voir sur un écran qu'on ne peut
pas avoir chez soi et cette expérience
elle est unique et en france en
particulier on est privilégiés puisque
on a sans doute un des plus beaux parcs
de salles du monde si ce n'est le plus
beau pour ce qui est des jeunes comme
vous l'avez préciser tout à l'heure les
chiffres de juin sont très très bons 40
% des entrées salles de gens ont été
réalisés par les jeunes par contre ce
qui énerve les professionnels de la
profession les fameux c'est que la part
de films français ou de films d'art et
essai ne plaît pas forcément aux jeunes
ils vont plutôt avoir tendance à aller
vers les grands blockbusters les grandes
comédies et effectivement je crois que
le cinéma français chez les jeunes c'est
aux alentours de 20% de représentation
des entrées salles donc il ya un petit
challenge mais à un moment donné c'est
aussi le jeu de l'offre et la demande et
si les jeunes désertent tout ce cinéma
là qui est peut-être un cinéma qui fait
plaisir à des gens plus âgés
il faut aussi que les réalisateurs les
créateurs s'adapte à ce que le jeune
public veut qui lui aussi a sa forme
d'exigence et malheureusement c'est vrai
que les plateformes peut être
aujourd'hui tendance un peu à déformer
les goûts des jeunes
parce que cette profusion de filmer et
de genre qui sort comme ça tous les
jours avec des nouveautés qu'on n'arrive
même pas regardé peut effectivement les
détourner un moment donné de la tension
de la salle qui est très packagées qui
est très éditorialisé qui est très bien
présenté alors que de l'autre côté on a
plutôt quelque chose quelqu'un avait un
jour utilisé l'expression d'un burger
flix pour symboliser les plateformes
c'est peut-être ça la question
aujourd'hui est ce que est ce que tout
ça n'est peut-être pas par hasard le
statut du cinéma me semble-t-il a changé
puisqu'on parle des jeunes là le cinéma
perdu de son importance les messages on
l'a dit ne sont plus des temples ils ont
pris l'habitude de regarder des films
ailleurs que sur dans les salles mais
surtout les films ont perdu de leur
prestige
quand j'étais adolescent il fallait en
guettaient la sortie d'un film parce que
quand il allait être en salle et puis
comme dit mindi serait plus ce serait
trop tard
il passerait peut-être à la télévision
vingt ans plus tard je parle des grands
films aujourd'hui ça n'a plus rien à
voir les films sortent en salles et puis
ensuite ils attendent qu'on veuille bien
les regarder
ils sont en vod ils sont sur les plates
formes ils sont en dvd ils sont partout
les films le film n'a plus du tout
l'importance le côté sacré qu'il pouvait
être avoir autrefois non oui non alors à
mais avant de répondre à votre question
je voulais lui par rapport à ce pont
d'idées
deux interlocuteurs tacle il ya quelque
chose dans la vision il ya deux choses
dans ce qu'il avait dit chloé la vision
quantitative
moi je m'en méfie terré évidemment
terriblement parce que la président du
cnc dont vous parliez que tu es
frédérique bredin à l'époque
effectivement se félicitait du nombre
d'entrées salle mais pour moi c'est pas
du tout un indicateur c'est un
indicateur économique intéressant mais
qui dit pas grand chose si 19 millions
de gens de voir intouchable ou 19
millions personnes vont voir le parrain
de coppola pour moi c'est pas la même
chose
dark à ce moment là je ne sais plus est
ce que je défends la même chose quand je
défends 19 millions de spectateurs qui
vont voir une comédie française insipide
infime part veule ou une fast and
furious riz quelconque ou alors qu'ils
vous quand ils vont voir un film de todd
haynes de takeshi kitano ou de john ford
ou de james gray 1
donc ça pour moi c'est très important
c'est qu'on reste à une vision
strictement comptable on manque
complètement le sujet la deuxième chose
me semble le team c'est que le il faut
être complètement aveugle pour ne pas
voir que la jeune génération évidemment
on dit les jeunes ils sont en 2 millions
à aller voir des films et qu'est ce
qu'ils vont voir les jeunes comme vous
dites ils vont voir des films marvel ils
vont voir des films de super héros
ils vont voir beaucoup de comédies
quelle est la part là-dedans je dirais
de cinéphiles un peu sérieux parmi les
jeunes hormis la cinémathèque et
quelques cinémas du cardio du quartier
latin je pense je parle à paris qui vont
voir des films qu'on appellerait le
cinéma pour moi face and furious et du
produit audiovisuel c'est quelque chose
qui est projeté sur un écran si mam
c'est pas du cinéma
pour moi une comédie avec dany boon en
dépit tout le respect que je peux avoir
pour tous ces gens là c'est pas du
cinéma c'est du produit audiovisuel ne
faut pas tout confondre
donc moi je dis il ya alerte rouge mais
il faut au contraire il faut juste aller
à partir de là qui me semble-t-il faut
réagir
je pense que pour la jeune génération
comme tu me vous dit frédéric
le cinéma n'est plus un art populaire au
sens et c'est plus une langue commune
tout simplement aujourd'hui c'est plus
la série vidéo c'est le jeu vidéo cd
vidéos sur youtube sur tik tok etc mais
moi qui ai des enfants
j'ai bien vu à paris centre j'ai bien vu
l'évolution quand j'étais adolescent on
était quinze vingts à désirer un film
qui sortait le mercredi toute la
sociales confondues aujourd'hui c'est
trois quatre fous furieux qui ont
entendu parler de kubrick hitchcock ou
de ford
donc faut pas se raconter d'histoires la
jeune génération
elle va peut-être autant salle qu'avant
mais elle ne veut pas voir
soit autant de fils de cinéma qu'avant
et je pense que pour moi toute la
question fondamentale c'est de se
demander est ce que c'est un paul
schrader ce cinéaste scénariste de taxi
driver m'avait dit lui qui était un vrai
catastrophiste je prends là je parle à
chloé lui disais mais le cinéma est né
s'est développée et puis un jour il va
forcément disparaître en tant que forme
d'art populaire
je pense qu'on en est là à ceux à cela
et me disait le cinéma aujourd'hui c'est
de la musique classique et c'est vrai
c'est pas parce qu'il ya bassano furious
à côté des marvel ou des comédies
françaises insipide que pour autant le
cinéma n'est pas devenue la musique
classique
il ya toujours du r'n'b du r'n'b
insupportable ou du vol codeurs dans des
chansons de rap mais il ya encore de la
vraie musique
mais est-ce que les gens qui sont
cinéphiles qui s'intéressent au cinéma
en tant qu'art uns et pas uniquement en
tant que demande par rapport à un public
sauf quand vous avez tout à l'heure oui
mais il faut que les plateformes les
cinéastes seront répondre un peu aux
exigences du jeune public mais non au
nom de quoi les lélés les cinéastes
devrait répondre à l'exigence d'un jeune
public ce jeune public va voir que
marvel faut éduquer les gens
la qualité du regard et les capitales on
peut pas suivre uniquement aveuglément
la question du marché me semble-t-il
alors réaction que oui volontiers
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses
c'est difficile de réagir parce que je
crois qu'on parle de plein de choses
différentes en même temps on peut pas
opposer le cinéma comme marché où le
cinéma comme produits audiovisuels ou le
cinéma comme industries culturelles qui
produirait des contenus versus quelque
chose qui en serait complètement
détachée qui serait le cinéma comme art
qui ne passerait pas par des circuits
marchands qui ne chercherait pas à faire
d'entrée salles et terrains donc déjà
cette opposition elle tient pas sur le
plan esthétique elle tient pas sur le
plan économique elle tient pas sur le
plan sociologique elle tient encore
moins sur le plan historique si on
refait un peu l'histoire du cinéma
justement comme art populaire il faut
pas non plus opposé le questionnement
économique et le questionnement
esthétique
je partage complètement le scepticisme
voire la méfiance de jean baptiste
aurait pour les chiffres pour la logique
comptable d'appréhension de voilà de ce
que c'est que le cinéma de ce qui fait
le cinéma
en revanche ça permet aussi d'éviter de
dire n'importe quoi je dis pas ça pour
bouger ça pour tous ces discours que je
cite un kiki qui tendent à voile à faire
comme s'il y avait une espèce d'énorme
va qui se déroulait sur l'art cinéma
graphique que seraient les plateformes
et qui serait un grand danger 1
je ne crois pas que les films avec dany
boon ou les films de la chaux ou les
comédies françaises dites insipide soit
nécessairement pas du cinéma ou du
mauvais cinéma donc sur ces questions là
j'aurais du mal à vous rejoindre parce
qu'on va avoir autant d'avis qu'il n'y
est cinéphile
alors bon je suis prof en fac de cinéma
je sais ce qu'est la bonne pensée
cinématographique et je peux vous faire
le discours mais je crois pas que ça
nous aidera à mieux comprendre ce qui se
passe à mieux comprendre les évolutions
des usages non je pense qu'il faut
absolument sortir de cette polarisation
justement de la production
cinématographique qui est qui est
autrement plus subtil que ça et bien sûr
que tout ne se vaut pas mais pas
intrinsèquement parce qu'on l'a décidé
aujourd'hui que ça c'était mieux que ça
et bien sûr que moi en tant que
spectatrice je partage un certain nombre
de hiérarchie et que je fais des
différences et que je ne prescrit pas
les mêmes choses à mes enfants mais si
on veut réfléchir un petit peu
scientifiquement ce qui n'est pas la
même chose que la logique quantitative
ou comptable on peut faire de la science
sensible qualitative humaines etc
je pense qu'il faut quand même se
départir un petit peu de sa hiérarchie
ou en tout cas les réinscrire est ce que
quand je ne sais plus je crois que
monsieur de chevalier qui parlait de
burgers fixe bon bah ça c'est un chant
rhétorique la culture pop corn le burger
la consommation la fast good movie culte
shirts et terrasses et enfin je veux
dire qu'on a ça depuis 76 et la sortie
du magnétoscope
donc c'est une rhétorique et réactive et
là par les plateformes et qui en fait
est une rhétorique d'opposition des
publics d'opposition des films je crois
qu'il faut plutôt justement travaillé à
ce qui les rassemble ses publics etc
et moi je ne suis pas particulièrement
catastrophé de voir des gens aller en
salle ou des jeunes allaient en savoie
redémarre dès lors ils sont les salles
sont assujetties à la même tsa et sa
finance les films français pour vieux
crâne vieux vieux crâne chauve et gris
donc on a la chance d'avoir un système
aussi de financement du cinéma français
qui permet cette circulation des publics
et des contenus pascal lechevallier
moi j'aimerais bien juste dire que je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure
plutôt sur un phénomène de
complémentarité moi je peux pas rentrer
dans le débat dollars on a beaucoup lu
récemment que c'est un film n'avait pas
enfin une oeuvre cinématographique ça
n'avait pas un numéro de visa ce n'était
pas un film et moi je en tant
qu'observateur je vois par exemple le
chemin parcouru par un réalisateur qui
est plutôt reconnu mondialement qui
s'appelle steven spielberg qui a eu à un
moment donné l'opportunité de pouvoir
cracher ou en tous les cas dire que les
plateformes c'était pas bien que le
cinéma ne pouvait pas être vu dans
l'écran des plateformes et puis la
semaine dernière où il ya dix jours on a
tous appris que steven spielberg s'était
entendu avec ted sarandos et reed
hastings netflix pour produire des films
alors est ce que ça veut dire que steven
spielberg est un grand cinéaste dans les
années 70 quand il travaillait que dure
jusqu'à ce et francis ford coppola qu'il
a fait de grandes oeuvres parce qu'elle
dit et vu d'abord dans des cinémas avec
des délais de de programmation très très
long qui faisait qu'on l'ait retrouvée
sur la télévision au clair quelques
années plus tard et puis que d'un seul
coup parce que steven spielberg a décidé
de suivre une évolution peut être aussi
créative je vous ramène aux propos de
martin scorsese qui dit qu'aujourd'hui
il a besoin de financer ces films parce
que le cinéma c'est aussi une économie
et que malheureusement aux états unis
pour les financer aujourd'hui il n'est
pas forcément suivi et donc ils se
tournent vers les plateformes pour
pouvoir exercer son art c'est lui qui le
dit c'est pas moi et c'est là où je dis
il faut pas opposer les blocs font les
accompagnent ont longé dans une
complémentarité dans un nouveau monde
que la valeur de cette oreille et c'est
là on est au milieu du gué et on essaie
de comprendre ce qui va se passer dans
tous les cas voilà pour moi le cinéma
les multiples et c'est pas parce que le
film va sortir sur une plateforme que
steven spielberg est devenu un mauvais
réalisateur et qu'il fait du mauvais
cinéma alors deux choses pour répondre à
chloé évidemment le 6 mai est aussi une
industrie malraux bon bien sûr personne
d'un peu intelligent même avec un
cerveau qui fonctionne même même à
faible régime n'oserait opposer les deux
le cinéma l'industrie on est tous
d'accord là dessus non il ya juste la
question je vous la question la
subjectivité qui me semble aussi
importante par rapport à ce que vous dit
et sur la question des comédies de
marvel et cetera moi j'aurai une
tendance mais pour radicaliser un peu un
plus pour réveiller le mammouth endormi
c'est un peu ça mon idée hein c'est que
je pense que la subjectivité c'est un
art c'est un peu un argument à double
tranchant il me semble voilà vous êtes
en scène dans en fac moi je n'étais
quelques années j'ai fait ma est pas là
mon petit parcours universitaire
classique cetera il me semble qu'on a
parfois un peu les goûts qu'on peut et
pas les goûts qu'on veut c'est à dire
que c'est un peu facile toujours de dire
il ya autant de goût que de couleur
c'est pas vrai quelqu'un qui a tout ça
vu avec toute sa vie pendant deux trois
ans a vu des finances tognoni de jacques
tati de john ford et de peckinpah à la
fin sa subjectivité ne sera pas de même
nature n'aura pas la même valeur que
celui qui aura vu que des films marvel
alors oui il a suffi que la suite imité
c'est comme les films d'auteur les films
d'auteur ou la fille de l'auteur ne dit
rien soit la question c'est est ce qu'il
ya des bons films d'auteur tout le monde
est un auteur même le pire ou le plus
médiocre des cinéastes
la question c'est est ce qu'il ya des
bons auteurs donc ça c'était pour
répondre à cette question là et par
rapport à ce que je gagnais je suis tout
à fait d'accord moi je ne posais pas du
tout pour l'instant en tout cas dans des
papes sans doute à ce stade la
discussion la plateforme et le cinéma
d'autant plus que j'ai toujours eu une
réticence à l'égard des gens qui
culpabilisait les pauvres cinéphiles qui
voyait des films autrement qu'en salle
pas du tout moi je pense que voir des
films c'est absolument important jeu la
question de la plateforme
mon avis est complètement différent c
est ce que la plateforme va me
semble-t-il on est au milieu du gué
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de statuer
de façon un peu terminale parce que la
plateforme a continué en draguant plutôt
les cinéphiles
on va chercher scorsese bong joon-ho les
frères safdie irishman évidemment on a
tous trouvé ça formidable à 70%
comme s'est félicité le patron de
netflix je ne sais pas ce que c'est que
par exemple aller voir un film en salles
à 70%
mais en tout cas voilà je trouve ça
formidable qu'il y ait eu quelques six
dates etc
mais à mon avis la plateforme les
plateformes la netflix amazon ou autre
il on lâche l'occasion de produire une
vraie diversité c'est ça mon avis
l'enjeu pour les plateformes aujourd'hui
comme il ya eu le nouvel hollywood à la
fin des années 60 il ya un marché pour
ça deux cent cinquante mille personnes
c'est pas énorme mais est ce que l'état
du marché aujourd'hui c'est pas une
agrégats
mon petit marché est ce que le netflix
va pas aller vers le fait de faire des
films pour ses différentes niches ou
alors il ya un désir totalitaire qui est
d'imposer ce que vous appuyez des
contenus moque je ne supporte absolument
pas et d'imposer le même contenu à tout
le monde alors numériquement ça marche
évidemment qui aura dix fois plus de
personnes qui iront voir wonder man band
2 ou alors batman 14 plutôt qu'à aller
voir un film de bong joon ho d'affaires
safdie ou de noël bombe de dabou bac par
exemple ça c'est vrai mais si netflix a
l'intelligence de se dire qu'il faut
qu'ils aient plusieurs conceptions du
cinéma effectivement le blockbuster mais
à côté de ça un autre type de film type
nouvel hollywood
là mon avis la plateforme peut devenir
intéressante puisque elle va pallier au
manque aussi de la production du cinéma
qui n'est pas non plus tout blanche là
dedans
le succès des plateformes vient me
semble-t-il aussi une par moments d'un
d'un défaut ou d'une faiblesse du
système notamment en france de
production distribution d'exploitation
dead le cnc enfin on connaît tous sens
ils nous on a juste deux minutes avant
le avant la pause mais réponse de et de
la porte et puis je vous donnerai la
parole après c'est pas vraiment une
réponse
on mélange de choses hein je redis en
oppose bons et mauvais film et on oppose
salle et plateformes
sauf qu'aucun des deux aucune de ces
deux aucun ces deux systèmes
d'opposition nenê parfaitement valide la
jean baptiste thoret site baumbach qui
fait des séries aussi pour netflix
netflix je veux dire les contenus pour
utiliser le mot bien sûr que je sais ce
qu'est la charge symbolique du mot mais
c'est quand même en ces termes que c'est
monétiser quand netflix produit du
contenu on va produire un film c'est pas
netflix qui produit ces netflix qui
produit appuyé sur une société de
production sur des équipes créatives des
créateurs et des créatrices en
l'occurrence la france est et peut-être
qu'on reparlera de ça donc
netflix n'est pas tout seul c'est pas
une espèce de machine qui fonctionne ça
s'appuie aussi sur des savoir faire
créatif artistique qui sont travaillés
dans d'autres dans d'autres champs ou
dans d'autres espaces cinéphilique donc
je je ça ne veut pas dire que tout ça se
vaut ni sur le plan qualitatif ni sur le
plan esthétique ou que sur le plan et
économique
il ne faudrait pas faire de distinctions
moi je suis absolument partisane d'une
régulation d'un encadrement d'un
assujettissement des plateformes aux
obligations de financement et c'est
justement parce que il faut arrêter
d'opposer et qui à un moment quand il ya
des concurrents sous des synergies
d'usagé
il faut qu'ils aient des concurrences et
des synergies économiques on va faire
une pause et on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
les plateformes sont elles l'avenir du
cinéma on en discute avec jean baptiste
aurait avec l'oeil de la porte et pascal
lechevallier parce que le chevalier
vouliez réagira je crois qu'on va on va
tomber d'accord on est face à un nouvel
environnement que toutes les oeuvres ont
le droit de vivre qu'elles vont trouver
leur place à tel ou tel endroit
moi je rappelle aussi que les
plateformes aujourd'hui et on a beaucoup
parlé de s vod donc les plateformes par
abonnement mais les plates formes à
l'acte ou permettent aussi de découvrir
des catalogues qui malheureusement ne se
trouve pas forcément en dvd puisque je
rappelle que les bd aujourd'hui est un
support en grande souffrance qu'on ne va
pas forcément retrouver dans des cycles
de festivals ou de cinéma cartier de
cinéma d'art et essai et donc la serène
dépité un ca le fait de rentrer dans une
plate forme de vidéo à la demande et de
pouvoir balayer des catalogues de les
visiter de chez soi alors certes dans un
espèce de confinement d'écran ça c'est
sûr mais ça permet aussi de découvrir et
de parfaire sa culture cinématographique
je rappelle aujourd'hui que mon nombre
de films de catalogue sont accessibles à
des prix très modeste et ça permet aussi
aux jeunes ces fameux jeunes dont on
parlait tout à l'heure de découvrir des
réalisateurs qu'on ne voit pas la
télévision puisque je rappelle que la
télévision au dessus a fait son travail
sur on va dire le un travail de sape
autour du cinéma on voit de moins en
moins de films sur les chaînes de
télévision tous les cas aux heures de
grande écoute et donc les plateformes
sont en train de remplacer cet espace où
on peut plus aller traîner chez un
vendeur de dvd je rappelle que tous les
vidéo clubs ont quasiment fermé et donc
si on veut approfondir sa connaissance
cinématographique des plateformes
aujourd'hui peuvent rendre ce service et
c'est pour ça que il faut les laisser
grandir et répondre aux besoins et aux
attentes du public
le le patrimoine cinématographique dieu
sait si les vastes aujourd'hui est ce
que est ce qu'il pourrait disparaître ou
est-ce qu'au contraire aujourd'hui il
est plus facile de voir des films de
toutes les époques que ça n'a jamais été
quand j'étais enfant il y avait la
cinémathèque il y avait le ciné club ce
qu'il est
te plaît à la télévision où on pouvait
voir les films en version originale
et puis il y avait des films qui
ressortait en salles l'été en général on
appelait ça les reprises
c'était pas si facile que ça de voir
king kong
quand on était pas on n'avait pas eu 20
ans en 1933
aujourd'hui c'est plus facile où c'est
plus compliqué mon avis c'est beaucoup
plus facile enfin moi je pense mène
d'ailleurs que le que le patrimoine est
presque on est ce que les plateformes
c'est l'avenir du cinéma en étant un peu
provocateur moi j'ai presque le
sentiment que c'est le patrimoine qui
est l'avenir du cinéma
je vois bien combien aujourd'hui les
cinéphiles en fait sont de plus en plus
intéressés par ce qu'on appelle le
patrimoine le patrimoine c'est des films
qui ont été arrêtés à plus de dix ans
donc et sont éligibles au patrimoine des
films qui date de 2010 ou 2011 s'est pas
uniquement des films muets noir et blanc
de l'époque du prêt code ou des péplums
des années 50 pas du tout donc moi je
pense que le au contraire le paie le
patrimoine aujourd'hui il ya même des
revues de l'état de la revue de la
critique est toujours intéressant parce
qu'on voit bien que les revues
historiques qui traite de l'actualité
sont de moins en moins lui parce que
l'actualité intéresse de moins en moins
les cinéphiles
ça veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas des
contenus qui intéresse des spectateurs
dans des salles de cinéma mais je parle
des gens qui aiment le cinéma
l'actualité les intéressent de moins en
moins et évidemment c'est un effet de
sablier et le patrimoine est devenu
quelque chose qui a pris une ampleur
capitale alors vous disiez le patrimoine
les plateformes heureusement qu'elles
sont là parce que patrimoine
oui je j'aimerais le croire
il n'empêche que aujourd'hui via il ya
eu da si la télévision ne passent plus
de deux films il ya eu des chaînes du
câble je pense à des chaînes comme
paramount chanel tcm disons qu'entre
patrick brion aujourd'hui s'est passé
des choses il s'est passé notamment des
chaînes du câble
le cas il y avait beaucoup d'offres
deuxième chose nous avait enterrés le
dvd et le blu ray alors je parle un peu
je prêche un peu pour ma chapelle mais
je crois que on va arriver à un moment à
une sorte de plancher de gens qui seront
plutôt des gens motivés un peu furieux
qu'ils savent très bien que regarder
quatre disques durs c'est pas la même
chose que regarder une dvdthèque c'est
comme une bibliothèque
bon donc le support physique a un sens
bien plus importants que le simple fait
de posséder un objet on n'a pas la même
vision des films et d'histoire du cinéma
qu'on le regarde et moi je j'ai plutôt
tendance à penser que le dvd le blu ray
ah ça évidemment a subi d
mou mais il va se stabiliser on en
produit énormément aujourd'hui les
grands groupes ont tendance à plutôt
abandonné ce qui était le cas de tf1 par
exemple vous vous le savez sans doute
mais il ya plein de petits éditeurs qui
aujourd'hui se crée alors son des micros
modèle c'est un type ou deux dans leur
cave qui vont aller chercher des
catalogues ont payé les droits de films
italiens oui tchèque mais c'est ça la
cinéphilie aujourd'hui est la somme de
tous ces petits éditeurs se fait la
cinéphilie donc je pense
qu'effectivement le patrimoine n'a
jamais été aussi accessible que ça et
aussi désirable que ça y'a qu'à voir le
succès des rétrospectives de fresques à
paris lors de l'été je pense qu'il ya
deux ans la rétrospective de 11 ou par
exemple vous connaissez les chiffres du
cnc il ya vingt films ou 18 qui sortent
par semaine quand vous regardez la
réalité des chiffres des entrées salles
la réalité 1 s'est souvent
catastrophique le nombre de films qui
font entre 800 et 3000 entrées il ya une
petite partie des films qui fonctionne
mais une immense majorité ne trouve pas
du tout son public
mais je crois que le patrimoine alors
mon avis est ce qui est devenu de plus
en plus désirable parce que on pourrait
presque dire qu'aujourd'hui en 2021
on peut rentrer en cinéma et explorer
patrimoine toute sa vie et c'est
formidable
oui j'ai une réponse un peu moins
romantique mais le patrimoine est
désirable mais surtout très désirée pour
le coup par les plateformes parce que en
termes d'acquisitions de contenu à bas
coûts c'est formidable on acquiert un
catalogue entier c'est moins cher ça
permet de flatter les cinéphiles en
disant regardez en visant à acquérir mk2
regarder on a tous truffaut regarder on
a tous chabrol où tout bresson là qui
vient d'arriver sur netflix donc
j'aimerais dire c'est le combo gagnant
c'est hyper désirable parce que c'est
moins cher parce qu'à la caution de
légitimité justement cinéphiles c'est là
jusqu'au jour c'est que la stratégie
d'acquisition d'une plateforme qui va
cibler du cinéma de patrimoine
c'est gagnant sur tous les plans c'est
la même stratégie qui fait que netflix
va acquérir des salles de cinéma juste
pour pouvoir sortir ses films pour
qu'ils puissent être en compétition à
cannes
pour l'instant ça coince encore mais
être en compétition aux academy awards
et cetera donc il ya un intérêt
économique pour le cinéma de patrimoine
je pense qu'il faut pas être naïf
pour le coup et imaginer que ce serait
qu'un intérêt cinéphilique
c'est un intérêt économique direct sur
les coûts d'acquisition des films et qui
en plus compte un peu l'herbe sous le
pied des cinéphiles donc oui c'est très
désirable mais il faut pas voilà il faut
pas être trop ravi de la crèche par
rapport à ces stratégies d'acquisition
parce qu'elles servent des intérêts
quand même économiques directes on
pourrait même y voir un petit peu du
pillage aussi catalogue sur certains
ayants droit qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens sur certains distributeurs n'ont
pas forcément les moyens de continuer à
entretenir a même cherché à diffuser les
films les envoyer en festivals même
quand ils sont déjà sorties etc
c'est sûr quand on a un catalogue ou
faire une plateforme qui arrive derrière
avec un gros chéquier c'est aussi une
solution donc pour le coup je ne suis
pas voilà je serai un peu un peu
méfiante sur cette stratégie sur cette
valorisation du cinéma de patrimoine
pas sur le plan esthétique bien sûr et
de constitution d'une culture
cinématographique
un mot sur spécial de 4 bis qui se
déroule en ce moment je me souviens du
festival de cannes c'était festival des
films qui allaient passer sur canal+
dans un an mais à l'époque canal+ aimait
l'idée d'avoir les films qui étaient à
cannes
même si vous êtes très très peu de
spectateurs ça faisait partie de l'image
que canal+ vous l'êtes avoir l'image de
la chaîne du cinéma
je doute aujourd'hui que netflix par
exemple veuille être la plateforme des
films qui sont pas de sortie au festival
de cannes
je pense que c'est exactement l'inversé
de ce que ça les intéresse pas du tout
je suis très étonné quand vous dites que
ils veulent ouvrir dans salles de cinéma
juste pour avoir un prix à cannes parce
qu'il a appris à cannes sa faim tire
plus personne me semble-t-il
et surtout pas la personne qui à payer
son abonnement à date fixe en tout cas
quand je regarde les films qui sont sûrs
d'être fixe ou sur amazon d'ailleurs il
ya même pas le nom du réalisateur
on est dans un autre monde
cannes et ça ça n'a rien à voir non
chloé pas tant que ça à dire que à la
fois effectivement en termes
d'éditorialisation quand on est sur des
plateformes de type netflix amazon prime
vidéo on est sur une éditorialisation je
fais allusion la mention du nom du
réalisateur ou la réalisatrice qui
n'existe pas donc on est sur une
éditorialisation de type très commercial
où on n'a pas forcément les informations
qui intéressent un ou une cinéphile mais
l'intérêt de netflix et d'amazon en
particulier netflix pour canet pour ses
grandes compétitions il est très très
important
ils ont créé en termes d'algorithmes de
recommandations on n'en parle pas là
mais c'est quelque chose aussi qui
caractérise les plateformes à en termes
de construction du goût jean baptiste
aurait parlé tout à l'heure et disait
j'ai noté la formule on à l'égout qu'on
peut ça c'est aussi des produits des
recommandations algorithmique il ya des
catégories maintenant proposée par
netflix qui sont films primés série
ayant reçu un emmy films primés dans une
compétition internationale
la stratégie d'acquisition netflix
depuis trois ans elle est d'acquérir les
films qui ont reçu le prix du jury à
cannes j'ai perdu mon corps pour je sais
plus calquée territoire l'amérique du
sud une partie de l'europe etc paiera
donc non non il ya un intérêt très
sérieux de netflix pour ces contenus là
en revanche c'est pas parce qu'ils vont
réussir à les monétiser en termes
financiers effectivement ça suscite peu
d'intérêt mais il faut l'image
cinéphilique c'est la même chose que
siné que canal+ qui l'a par exemple a
acquis les droits de diffusion des
grandes cérémonies de remise de prix
cinématographique qui diffuse les
lumières de la presse internationale
depuis deux ans c'est absolument pas
rentable pour eux ça leur coûte pas mal
d'argent mais ça permet à canal+
malgré la baisse de ses investissements
dans la production du cinéma français de
continuer à se dire chaîne du cinéma
donc en termes de soft power en termes
de diplomatie en termes de de poids sur
les politiques publiques
c'est quand même pas négligeable bien le
chevalier netflix l'expliquent dans
chacune de ses interviews
ils ont besoin de gagner des prix donc
d'être présents alors en particulier aux
états unis
et si possible avec
les cinémas qui l'ont racheté de pouvoir
postuler aux oscars parce que ils se
construisent une image et se
construisent aussi une image vis-à-vis
peut-être des créateurs des auteurs les
plus réticents en montrant qu'ils ont
acquis une légitimité qu'ils aiment le
cinéma ils le disent
vous savez c'est une société qui
fonctionne beaucoup avec des punchline
et aujourd'hui ça fait partie des
arguments comme le dit chloé de
déploiement et de conquête de netflix de
dire nous sommes les amis du cinéma et
donc on a on accorde une place aux films
primés que ce soit venise je rappelle
que netflix a fait de très très grosses
acquisitions dans un festival qui était
le festival de tous les éditeurs et
distributeurs indépendants qui était
trop tôt netflix et amazon ont créé des
razzias de films en achetant des films à
des prix qui défient toute concurrence
parce que ils veulent être aussi aimé de
la profession c'est aujourd'hui devenu
au delà d'une plateforme netflix est
devenu en studio et ça c'est aussi ce
qui préfigure le marché de demain
netflix est devenu un studio est un
studio qui récolte beaucoup de ce quart
puisque je crois que l'année dernière
c'est le studio qui a récolté le plus de
ce quart alors ce n'est 10-15 oscar
récompense vraiment le les bons films ce
les films qui resteront son histoire a
priori nous dit le contraire
c'était une année atypique 1 l'année
dernière je rappelle que y'avait que les
plateformes qui concourait puisque les
salles de cinéma taylor jean-baptise
juste un tout petit mot sur la question
du 2-2 de l'accès du patrimoine via les
plateformes poser la question frédéric
tu es que le patrimoine disponibile est
notamment via la question des dvd blu
ray enfin je vais sur netflix le simple
fait qu'ils aient pas le nom du
réalisateur
bah je sais pas c'est quelque chose
d'hallucinant c'est pas un détail c'est
pas évident
c'est hallucinant c'est comme si on
allait c'est un libraire quelconque et
on avait des titres de livres qu'on
faisait l'économie des gens des auteurs
qui ont écrit les livres tel qu'on est
capable aujourd'hui de vendre fast and
furious rai auro il ya le casting mais
on ne sait pas avec qui sait ya quelques
mots clés poursuite en voiture bikini
action très bien et on va aller voir
chez pas moi monsieur klein ou un flic
de melville et là on le
non de melvin n'apparaîtra pas c'est
hallucinant donc est ce qu'on peut
vraiment se targuer de profs d'aller
promouvoir le patrimoine indépendamment
de la dimension un peu cynique dont
chloé parlais tout à l'heure
lorsqu'on nommé même pas le nom du
réalisateur il ya je ne comprends même
pas d'un point de vue stratégique
comment netflix fait pour oublier ça
nous vraiment deuxième chance est un peu
sévère parce que quand ils nous sortent
tous les truffes au il faut bien entendu
parce qu'il ya une opération marketing
chez autres font absolument donc lorsque
la plupart des films qui sont rachetés
par netflix produit par netflix ou
récupérées en boucle par netflix le nom
de return n'apparaît pas c'est quand
même me semble-t-il incroyable
2 le patrimoine c'est pas uniquement
mettre un film sur une plate forme et
sur une bande passante le patrimoine
dans le cas du dvd blu ray c'est une
assez un accompagnement éditoriales sont
des bonus ont des suppléments sont des
entretiens dire que quand vous allez
effectivement sur la case truffaut de
netflix
bah je vais regarder un film de truffaut
alors dernier mais trop peu importe un
phare à nay très bien mais est-ce que je
vais produire un contenu éditorial qui
va accompagner le film le prolonger
vis-à-vis de l'oeuvre du cinéaste de sa
période et c'est le dvd blu ray reste de
ce point de vue là incomparable que le
même film proposé sur netflix ou le même
film proposé par un éditeur de dvd
blu-ray indépendance et pas du tout la
même chose
le oui à l'accès au patrimoine mais il
ya un accès aveugle d'un côté puis dire
un peu voilà dans la grande masse il ya
un accès informé de l'autre et dernière
chose que vous disiez tout à l'heure
moi je pense que le pour moi l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire mais
netflix va prendre les plateformes une
place de plus en plus importante
est-ce qu'ils vont être capables en fait
de produire c'est ça pour moi parce que
quand on voit les films 100 % et flix
par 100% netflix je parle pas de films
qui ont été conçus à l'extérieur du
l'ancien système racheter une fille née
par netflix scorsese y en a beaucoup
d'autres est plutôt des films réussis tu
sais je parle des productions netflix
donc on voit les compétences des gens de
netflix est catastrophique les films
100% netflix 95 pensons ce sont des
navets des films totalement formaté
déformé ya un effet de régression c'est
quelque chose d'incroyable
donc pour moi la chance de netflix et de
se dire ou bien effectivement ils se
disent que ces films qui sont des navets
cartonne auquel cas tout va bien rien de
neuf sous le soleil les signifie six
cent mille personnes
oublions les ou alors ils ont conscience
car il ya plusieurs marchés et qui a
peut-être falloir apprend
à produire et apprendre à produire des
films ou des contenus des films
différents
là que quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
des films netflix c'est consternant
aussi bien esthétiquement d'un point de
vue dramaturgique
du point de vue du politiquement correct
le cinéma ça doit un peu chatouiller ça
doit gratouiller on peut pas faire
plaisir à tout le monde en même temps et
cette espèce de volonté un peu
oecuméniques de netflix de parler à tout
le monde donc à personne fait qu'on
produit des espèces pour le coup d'essai
c'est presque du niveau du jeu vidéo ou
de la mauvaise série b de l'époque
donc pour moi l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
de se dire est-ce que netflix a
conscience est ce qu'elle a envie
et est ce qui l a la capacité de 2,2
d'être à la hauteur de ce que vous
disiez c'est bien d'être un studio mais
on peut se décréter studio veut pas dire
qu'on en ait un
est-ce qu'ils ont les capacités les
qualités le désir de produire vraiment
des films autres shows autrement que
toutes ces espèces de film d'une heure
35 formaté voilà qui qu'hier qui font un
peu mal à notre rétine et qui nous
éduque pas beaucoup qui nous élève pas
beaucoup alors c'est sûr qu'après 10 ans
de films netflix
on pourra voir des soudards veulent mais
on est aussi un peu responsable de la
rétine des spectateurs me semble-t-il
clé de la porte
je suis pas je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec jean baptiste thoret sur les sur
deux choses 1 parce que c'est
précisément parce pas ce que fait
netflix de parler à tout le monde
la stratégie de production de contenus
et la stratégie d'acquisition netflix
est justement des micros segments de
marché et des micro-niches et donc c'est
pas du tout de produire des films qui
plairait à tout le monde ce qui peut
être pour le coup une stratégie de
studio plus classiques type majors
américaines
m6 où le marvel cinématiques universe et
ses ouailles à cette volonté un peu de
voix là d'aller toucher large dalle est
inondé la planète et tous les écrans du
monde pour le coup notre fric c'est
parce qu'ils visent ils ont justement
avoir une politique de contenus très
ciblé deux micro niches et c'est alors
qu'ils posent question aussi en tout cas
qui a interrogé par les sociologues des
économistes
qu'est ce que c'est que faire un film
pour la niche lgbt qu'est ce que c'est
que faire un film pour la niche des
étudiants du campus qu'est ce que c'est
que faire un film pour la niche j'en
sais rien
l'afrique américain il y en a beaucoup
ah oui alors bon mais après on peut
refaire aussi l'histoire de la
blaxploitation c'est pas les plateformes
qui ont inventé ça non plus donc toutes
les stratégies dont on est en train de
parler depuis le début ne sont pas
inventé ni par netflix ni par les autres
acteurs gars femmes etc
ça veut pas dire que c'est bien donc
c'est mal ça veut juste dire que j'ai
envie de dire c'est le capitalisme c'est
pas les plateformes
donc si on veut vraiment discuté
économiquement de quelque chose de
l'accès des publics aux oeuvres de la
fonction d'éducation d'élévation du
regard de l'esprit critique etc
je pense qu'il faut avoir une discussion
sur le modèle économique de production
de circulation des oeuvres et de la
culture
mais c'est pas les actes c'est pas les
plateformes la plaisance est une
technologie de mise en relation
numérique de deux choses bon qu'on le
fait pour tout et n'importe quoi c'est
pas la plateforme qu'il faut incriminer
ce qu'il faut incriminer c'est la
concentration des entreprises du secteur
au sein d'un petit nombre d'acteurs
parce que si l'enjeu c'est la diversité
c'est là que la diversité elle est
menacée
pascal lechevallier
quand vous entends parler je me pose une
question puisque la le décret smad vient
d'être publié et vous savez qu'il ya des
obligations qui vont peser sur sur ces
plateformes dont on dit qu'elles ne sont
pas les amis du cinéma mais il ya de
fortes chances quand même que si la
chronologie des médias et toutes les
discussions se terminent 20 de bonnes
conditions
finalement ce ces plateformes vont
devenir les principaux financiers du
cinéma de demain donc va vraiment
falloir réfléchir à comment on a envie
de les traiter et de parents très donc
le dans des systèmes de de bashing
systématique ou en tous les cas de
décrier ce qu'elles font et puis surtout
comme l'a dit chloé à l'instant une des
difficultés c'est cette espèce de
verticalisation du monde des médias qui
tenteront d'ailleurs de se produire en
france je vous rappelle que il ya de
grands groupes qui vont se rapprocher et
donc on est en train de découvrir un
nouveau monde dont les paramètres
d'existence vont complètement changer et
au milieu de ça il ya effectivement le
cinéma qui peut-être avec une bouée en
train de m'en servais cesse en disant
sauvez-moi sauvez-moi du capitalisme
sauvez-moi deux de ces oligo
qui vont massacrer la création ça on le
sait pas mais c'est vrai que on est
peut-être le cinéma peut être menacé par
ça et donc risque de souffrir dans les
années prochaines mais encore une fois
dans ces cas là faut pas demander aux
plateformes de venir sauver le cinéma
français et la création si une
considèrent que leur argent n'est pas le
bienvenu parce qu'ils ne font pas des
beaux films le cinéma c'est plutôt bien
accommodé du capitalisme les gros
studios hollywoodiens obéissait à des
logiques comptables très précise et ça
ne les a pas empêchés de faire des
chefs-d'oeuvre est vraiment des
chefs-d'oeuvre en nombre considérable y
avait au fond un souci économique et un
souci artistique qui pouvait être
faire mon ménage évidemment mais après
on parle aussi d'une époque où le disons
que là vous parlez des studios
américains
il n'y avait pas le cnc il n'y avait pas
les aides d'état tant qu'on fait pas on
faisait pas des films forcément pour
avoir un statut social
c'était des gens qui avaient une
histoire personnelle qui aimait le
cinéma qui prenaient des risques toscan
a été en france un des derniers dans les
années 80 aujourd'hui il ya des gens
comme maraval on les connaît c'est des
gens qui essaient de faire des films
indépendamment du système étatique voilà
parce qu'en france on produit beaucoup
un cinéma d'état alors c'est moins
violent qu'en corée du nord mais le
principe à peu près le même il faut
plaire on passe devant des commissions
il faut qu'il ya un certain type de
quotas un certain tu as certain type
d'art proches etc
il faut surtout que la télévision il
faut que ça danse ça oui mais ça c'est
vrai mais ça c'est surtout les années 80
les années 80 90 où finalement on s'est
retrouvé à avoir beaucoup de films
français au cinéma qui étaient des films
de télévision parce que je suis d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit à bien le chevalier
deçà de ce qu'on fait on attend beaucoup
de netflix et des plateformes parce que
vous avez raison ils vont prendre sans
doute un rôle de plus un port plus en
plus important dans la production et
dans dans la distribution exploitation
des films c'est évident donc ils ont des
devoirs et donc moi j'ai envie d'être
extrêmement optimiste prenait au sérieux
le rôle qui va vous est donnée qui est
absolument capital pourquoi apprendre à
produire des vrais films ne faut pas
mépriser les gens donc moi je crois
beaucoup en et flix l'autre chose qu'on
nous on a tendance à un peu oublié ces
cas on a le sentiment qu'il ya l'agneau
du cinéma tout frêle formidable
historiquement contre hull espèce de
loups de numerix il ya un moment tu veux
dire on en a il faut quand même rappeler
qu'on a mis en salle pendant des années
des années beaucoup de films qui ne
ressemblait pas à des films la queue on
paye aussi le fait que beaucoup de gens
allaient dans des salles du cinéma parce
que faut pas oublier qu'il ya des gens
qui payent les tickets de cinéma
sapec 10 ou 12 euros et c'est cher et
c'est extrêmement cher et qu'ils avaient
sur des écrans de cinéma je pense
notamment une grande partie de la
production française
il faut le dire d espèce d'objet qui
ressemblaient à des téléfilms
voilà pas très bien joué avec des
acteurs de télévision il ya eu toute
cette mode dévastatrice des gens qui
faisaient leur petit numéro de books
on sur canal et qu'on retrouvait ensuite
alors c'est sûr que convient des gens
qui viennent une génération les acteurs
c'était deux verres des nerfs ventura de
long et d'un seul coup je ne citerai pas
de noms des acteurs c'est ça il ya eu
une déperdition évidente de ce qu'on a
mis dans des devant les dents les écrans
de cinéma
ce qui fait que la salle de cinéma c'est
bien mais c'est encore mieux quand il ya
un film qui est projeté dans les salles
de cinéma et on a passé beaucoup de
temps aussi à démodé et is est ce que
c'est que le cinéma en y projetant
n'importe quoi et on en paye en partie
aujourd'hui le prix et pourquoi pas
aller sur une plateforme sur une
plateforme pourquoi de parader sur le ca
sur un écran d'ordinateur 21 pouces
puisque en déplaçant j'ai un téléfilm
grand écran sur un grand écran quelle
est la différence qu est ce qu il vaut
mieux en réalité et je pense que le
cinéma a aussi enfin tous les acteurs du
secteur aussi des questions à se poser
alors je dirais pas faire leur
inventaire faire leur mea culpa mais ils
sont co-responsables de la situation qui
arrivent et de la révolution qui arrive
qui je l'espère en tout cas
comme comme comme nous tous ici produira
le meilleur mais on est à un moment on a
un moment voilà déjà un peu flottant
d'hésitation au milieu du guet et ça
peut produire le meilleur le redémarrage
du cinéma véritablement anton car
populaire n'aura populaire il ya les
deux gaillards et à populaire qui a
aussi industrie pour faire plaisir à re
à chloé et puis il peut on peut aussi
totalement balayé le cinéma comme art
populaire qui deviendra de la musique
classique pour cinéphiles petit
communauté qui aura ses revues ses codes
sa langue c'est tout à fait possible
le problème c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut
produire des films de qualité des films
de cinéma
lorsque le public in fine est qu'on va
toucher ses cent mille personnes c'est
ça la vraie question dernier mot que de
la porte
que de mépris que de mépris pour l'amour
fou d'amour alors certainement que
d'amour mais il faut aller le chercher
loin parce que quand même j'ai donc
j'aimerai pas être productrice de films
de cinéma et vous entendre parce que il
ya quand même une forme de passéisme
cinéphilie qui fait que ce serait bien
avant sauf que quand j'entends ce qui
est cité avant fin je suis pas sûr que
les parents des adolescents qu'ils
allaient voir les films du nouvel
hollywood en 69 70 71 72 étaient super
contents que leurs enfants n'aillent pas
avoir du fun classicisme hollywoodien
donc
jean baptiste aurait qui connaît très
bien ces périodes-là qui connaît très
bien ses chants là et ces objets-là voit
bien comment est-ce que ces prix en
contexte et comment est-ce que ce qui
est la culture populaire de l'un et la
culture élitiste de l'autre et que ses
marques et aussi de façon générationnel
donc moi j'aimerais quand même qu'on me
réponde qu'est ce que c'est qu'un bon
film qu'est ce que c'est qu'un mauvais
parce qu'on fait tous depuis le début
comme si on voyait très bien quoi on
parlait et je suis désolé de faire la
scientifique
relou du débat mais qu'elle est sûre
quel indicateur mesure ça si c'est la
seule subjectivité de jean baptiste
thoret je crains que ce soit un peu
limité pour penser les politiques
culturelles à l'échelle mondiale donc
s'il ya autant de subjectivité et que
bien sûr elles s'accordent certes mais
il faut un moment prendre un peu de
large et justement revenir moi je crois
qu une des choses les plus intéressants
qui a été dit au début et je m'arrêterai
là dessus c'est justement ce qu'a dit
jean baptiste aurait il faut que les
gens voient des films le plus de films
possible le plus de meilleur film
possible certainement mais voir des
films c'est quand même peut-être ce qui
reste aujourd'hui la danse est de
transition le plus important je dis ça
c'est clairement un appel au maintien de
l'ouverture des salles quelle que soit
la situation sanitaire
pascal lechevallier d'animaux très vite
très vite et bah j'ai cité le mépris ou
jack palance dit que son cinéma va
fermer va être rempli par remplacer par
un trisomique et dit le cinéma est mort
et michel piccoli lui répond en disant
non je crois que le cinéma ne manquera
jamais allé dans un film de godard et le
nom de godard est cité au début du film
voyez ce que je veux dire il faut il
penser qu'en dans le cadre des
plateformes
merci tous les trois d'avoir participé à
ce débat merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro mais
surtout à la fin du mois d'août puisque
ce sont désormais les vacances que je
vous souhaite très agréable on se
retrouve dans un bras
[Musique]